[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il est mignon ya un petit cadeau
attendez mon chéri je veux juste te
faire ça pour qu'il respire il ya eu des
choses de hauts faits qui se sont passés
à wil et chéri des chose de fou et il a
tout vu
ah oui aujourd'hui quand je vous dis que
c'est du très très lourd l'indiquent de
la rédac
puis il vous balance tout ce qui se
passe quand les courses à wil vous
balance tout ce qui se passe pendant
l'émission il vous balance tout ce qui
se passe même au pureau maintenant il
paraît et c'est ça et c'est ce qu'on va
voir puisque j'ai voulu aujourd'hui
commencer un peu autrement cette
chronique cyril alors l'indiquent de la
rédac vous le savez donc vous l'aï dit
je suis en plateau je suis en coulisses
mais je suis également à la rédac du
gazole indique de la rédac it assuré
hier rappelez vous recevez le producteur
guillaume genton c'est vrai mon amour
qu'on aime tout ce qui est très sympa
mais guillaume quand vous l'avez
accueillis il a lancé une petite phrase
qui m'a pas laissé indifférent non une
phrase qui m'a fait tilt
regardez magnéto et vous allez voir mon
enquête juste après on reçoit ce soir le
réalisateur le producteur ou le style le
styliste conseiller visage à sa belle
peau cyril très belle épiderme
américains très bas l'épiderme l'a
souvent dit vous aussi merci voilà je
suis à la rédaction cyril j'ai voulu
enquêter savoir comment vous faisait
pour avoir un aussi bel épinière pour
être si reluisant chaque jour que ce
soit à la télévision ou au bureau lui
jean reno exemple vous vous preniez quoi
du coup de cyril lundi qu'à trouver la
réponse
car lundi qu'à ses sources lundi qu'à
ses sources même au bureau et on vous a
filmé à votre insu à dans votre bureau
[Musique]
avant tout nos biens
j'ai la même heure voilà je te le jure
que c'est vrai pas celui que c'est déjà
ça met une crème c'est très américain
je sais c'est un espèce de gel que tu
mets mes apprête à la crème hydratant
dessus des trios paraît non non je les
ai après un bond dans ce qu'on appelle
un truc on a fait comme ça en fait tu le
mets comme ça comme pacman et tu te
réveilles on équipe et remet le matin
décès du moose un lait végétal ans c'est
pas un digital c'est vraiment ceni c'est
cette élection crédible et mal 45 où tu
galères des cars chicken pas tu connais
pas c'est quoi la gym mais je peux pas
et je planais ce qui passe je croit
souvent que j'ai pas éteint la lumière
tellement de gens
m
mais ces beautés des discussions
urgentes est un ami oui notre influence
sur beauté quoi passer mon but mais
d'ailleurs bell et pizza fais gaffe à
segari maintenant sa filmo bureau ça
fait partout je ne la laisserai rien
passer et non par l'autre bafouillages
puisque john bafouillis on va
s'intéresser à jean-michel merde alors
il chez les verres transitions
jean-michel j'ai une photo accablante
parce qu'on peut la voir origines s'il
vous plaît oui vous souvenez l'amant de
jean michel et jean pascal deux jours
pascal bats wiki est due à devenu l'âme
ont déjà lancé dès la semaine dernière
on l'avait montré que jean michel était
un homme de conviction que jean-michel
et met ses amis et qu'ils étaient
capables de devenir très sympa si on lui
offrait des cadeaux et bien cette
semaine
en réalité je crois que jean michel n'a
aucune phase jean-michel n'a pas de
valeur
jean michel est capable du pire même
avec ses propres amis vous savez comme
on l'appelle dans la langue de molière
le gros tard bas
si jean pascal sera pascal gens parce
qu'ils te trouve très beau peut pas
réclamer à 8,11 into mis sa voix qui
parle des gaules et agitateur way
je suis pas si sûr choix parce qu'ils
sont pas aux normes
la banquette
gaza 4 mois leur nombre et c'est là où
il est mort gemini jean pascal aura fait
aussi beaucoup
[Musique]
n'empêche pas ses clés
des grands
oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça ouais on a d'autres choses qui
pour avoir des preuves de transit dans
l'équipe à votre avis en bas tout le
monde ici alors pas sympa bon on va voir
dans le magnéto qui est des problèmes de
transit
je vous donne deux indices le premier
c'est pas benjamin castaldi oui c'est
charrier avec ça et le deuxième est bien
à votre avis qui ça peut être je sais
pas il a des gros problèmes de pied un
conseil cyril vous approchez pas des
toilettes des chroniqueurs pour y avoir
de très très gros prenant on regarde ça
fait du bien mon fils quand 17h30 c'est
comme on dit encore cela coulante à la
bagarre et ben écoute tu le sauras tu as
la villa corse
mais toi ça c'est toi tous les jours
tavannes vraiment ça va mieux ça oui on
en trouve en amont ty mais on a un truc
sur vous et je suis ambitieux parce
qu'après on va m'indiquer on va voir
m'accuser d'être praticables
c'est quoi bah oui eh bah vous allez
voir ce que c'est parce que vous savez
la semaine dernière par un amour de
patron bien sûr ont charrié un peu le
fait que vous soyez ambianceur clash
heures bien sûr performeur parce que
c'est vrai cyril que vous êtes un photo
de ma gueule un très grand animateur et
non pas du tout vous êtes un très grand
animateur pour le patron du paf
enfin vous êtes également un très bon
danseur avant tout un performeur cyril
et j'ai réuni tout vos qualités dans un
seul magnéto moment et je le diffuser à
une condition quoi une augmentation
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
sur le fait que tard et je t'aime bien
ta grand-mère à moi ton cas ces traits
de jeu m du d'époux 30 samedi mais vous
dans la loterie
ouais ben ali
yeah
à voir les walis non
excuse moi tu as pas d'autres amis à qui
tu peux parler à part moi ben ali
ce come back on doit finir dans ton cul
alors comprenez vous cette décision
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
son père
oui je ne me reconnais pas le vrai
visage des fonctionnements
alors comprenez vous cette décision
[Applaudissements]
donc on a vu là à la fin nous étions un
performeur cyril sur prêts et vous êtes
capable de danser sur tout mais quand je
dis tout on a fait des petits tests vous
allez voir vous êtes un très très grand
performeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui les rendait le comico
daumas et je l'avais répète pas deux
fois et je vais la voir ma mère voix
[Musique]
basse aux fous de ma gueule c'est sûr et
certain
j'aime bien la tique d'entrer votre vrai
visage
oui oui mario bava membres et 10 as tu
pourra le lire demain aux attraits
religion sert il a en tout cas
mais pour finir pour finir on va
s'intéresser à bernard montiel gard
bernard est ce que vous n'êtes pas un
tout petit peu schizophrène par hasard
si asus nous n'y a pas plusieurs bernard
6,6 parce que moi j'ai tourné le bernard
chineurs ça dépend de l'heure je connais
le bernard bagarreur ouais et je connais
le bernard bilingue il ya beaucoup de
bernardin bernard way regardez le
magnéto qui va suivre
c'est le grand retour de bernardi new
look
[Musique]
là c'est encore l'histoire quatre temps
donné
[Musique]
l'imam ans avoue craquer les filles ça
vous excite
tu es tu as
non
où la mer le générique tout à l'heure
j'étais en loge je parlais avec lionel
stan je réduisais le directeur général
et je lui disais mais alors lionel est
ce qu'il ya un salaire qu'on peut donner
une feuille oui tu peux donner celui de
bernard montiel puisque lui viendrait
pour 1,40 bayonne alston
[Applaudissements]
merci